[Musique]
bienvenue sur ce plateau
réalisé en collaboration avec
l'université des maires qui se tient
actuellement et qui sera consacré à un
thème qui sera sans doute le thème
majeur de l'élection présidentielle
celui de la sécurité mais c'est un thème
aussi sur lesquels les maires sont de
plus en plus en première ligne on l'a vu
récemment avec des événements violents
qui ont lieu par exemple à poissy à mais
quels sont les pouvoirs quels sont les
compétences des maires dans cette
dans ce domaine c'est une des questions
que nous allons imposer à nos invités
joséphine coltman sperger bonjour
monsieur vous êtes la mère de plaisir et
vice président du conseil départemental
etienne longerons bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le maire de montrouge et nicolas
mahut de bonjour vous êtes rumeurs de la
verrière
alors bonjour ça va bien d'abord une
question peut être un peu général
vis-à-vis de vos administrés de des
habitants de vauville quand il ya un
problème de sécurité qui se pose est ce
que c'est vers le maire que les
administrés se tourne mais
indéniablement oui indéniablement oui
puisque aujourd'hui vous le savez est
depuis toujours les maires sont en
première ligne
et si la personnalité que les personnes
n'en fallu dire que les habitants
connaissent que plus est en règle
générale ils ne connaissent pas non plus
les distances et les responsabilités des
uns et des autres il faut une vraie
différenciation entre la police
municipale et routes nationales malgré
tout qu'ils considèrent que nous avons
toutes les responsabilités et le portage
de bien sûr des réponses nous attendent
donc oui indéniablement oui les maires
sont en première ligne pour prendre ces
responsabilités là même si on n'en a pas
toujours la capacité et les moyens mais
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
parler
notre seul ben oui on va parler après
voilà en effet des des compétences des
moyens d du droit mais sur sept sur
cette demande au fond de la population
et ils n'ont joué nicolas de la ville
tout à fait d'accord pour dire que les
maires sang comme on le faisait avant
les engueulades et quand il ya un
problème dans une vie de ces véreux ces
derniers se tournent et diatement et
comme disait ma collègue de plaisir on a
beau leur expliquer que c'est la faute
de l'état où la faute d'untel ou d'untel
ils en ont rien à ils n'ont rien à faire
donc le vrai sujet c'est c'est la
capacité que nous avons nous les élus
locaux et les maires et leurs équipes en
particulier à répondre à ces
problématiques et on est souvent un peu
impuissant à cesser sa puissance qu'il
faut contre laquelle il faut lutter
parce que c'est vrai que c'est assez
insupportable d'avoir à dire aux
concitoyens écouter on n'y peut rien et
le voilà donc c'est vraiment ça le sujet
et on est vraiment en première ligne
c'est évident nicolas mainville c'est
vrai que ça a été aussi un des thèmes
peut-être de votre campagne à la
verrière la sécurité exactement et
peut-être pour illustrer ce que disait
mon collègue m sur l'impuissance sur un
thème très précis qui est celui des
rodéos sauvages à dour ou les mères
alerte les maires mettent en place des
caméras de vidéosurveillance les maires
essaie de s'emparer de cette thématique
mais on a l'impression d'avoir un vrai
sentiment d'impuissance face à ces
comportements puisque il relève de la
compétence de l'état pour mener leurs
enquêtes pour confisquer le cas échéant
la moto pour arrêter les conducteurs et
donc voilà c'est une un thème un exemple
parmi d'autres mais qui montre que on
essaye d'agir mais que les mères seules
sont malheureusement alors nous en nous
menant au droit au fond le le le maire
détient des pouvoirs de police générale
spéciale pour maintenir la sécurité
assurer la tranquillité des habitants
mais concrètement quelles sont ses
pouvoirs il veut répondre qu'on avait
peut-être de ne pouvoir sont vastes
quand vous prenez la liste quand vous
regardez les responsabilités des mères
la liste est impressionnante de nos
responsabilités qui vont véritablement
dans tous les sens mais je parle de
responsabilité on ne parle pas de
pouvoir là il ya une vraie différence
entre ce qu'on nous incombent comme
responsabilités et les pouvoirs qu'on
nous donne donc aujourd'hui on est
obligé je dirais d'inventer même
certaines modes de fonctionnement alors
bien sûr toujours dans la légalité mais
par exemple nos polices municipales
aujourd'hui ce sont des polices
municipales que nous devons pratiquement
je dirais professionnaliser voix rare
mais la plupart de mes collègues
aujourd'hui sur l'agglomération de saint
quentin sont dans cette réflexion là et
on doit aussi mutualiser un maximum avec
les collectivités environnantes
c'est ce que nous essayons de faire
parce que bien sûr il ya la répression
mais il ya aussi tout ce qui est
prévention je suis très attaché à toute
cette démarche là puisque je crois
qu'aujourd'hui quand nous avons des
quartiers comme nous avons un plaisir en
politique de la ville on se retrouve
bien sûr avec des comportements sur ces
quartiers qui sont des comportements qui
sont à l'arrêt la julie rey à la
frontière entre la possibilité que nous
avons au niveau de la police municipale
et de nos préventionniste puisque nous
avons des préventionnistes et avec le
travail que nous faisons en
collaboration étroite avec la police
nationale
donc la frange est la limite et parfois
je dirais pieds nus mais l'important et
je termine là dessus pour laisser place
à des collèges de la porter c'est la
collaboration que nous devons avoir
ensemble entre la police nationale et la
police municipale
oui c'est très intéressant d'ailleurs
parce que il ya quelques années le jeune
existence même d police municipale salle
des débats incroyable aujourd'hui
personne ne remet en cause l'existence
des policiers ici sont le débat oui vous
l'avez vous avez abordé jeu c'est
finalement dispersés c'est celui de est
ce que les polices municipales doivent
être armés ou pas c'est sa mémé
l'existence même des polices municipales
plus personne de l'armée en cause et
qu'elle mange au oui tout à fait nouveau
à montrouge on a vécu un épisode
dramatique nous
et peut-être quelques années en 2015 en
janvier 2015
une de nos policière municipale a été
assassiné le fameux coulibaly à la suite
des attentats contre charlie hebdo et
donc notre police municipale a été
totalement décapité puisque évidemment
après cette ces événements le moral de
chacun était dans les chaussettes et on
avait déjà une police municipale qui
était réduite à la portion boureux est
donc là on était vraiment proche proche
de zéro et donc il a fallu reconstruire
complètement cette dynamique et nous
avons choisi on avait pas de chef de la
police municipale c'est difficile à
recruter donc on a recruté un nouveau
chef
une nouvelle équipe et on leur donnant
des perspectives la perspective s'était
alors donné des moyens d'abord et
ensuite de les inscrire au 10 politique
un peu globale donc les moyens on aura
donné un nouveau nouveaux hôtels de
police municipale on a créé un centre de
supervision urbaine et on les a comme à
plaisir ont décidé de leur donner un
armement
si vous n'avez pas moins de policiers
municipaux vous avez des gardes
champêtres
c'est assez simple aujourd'hui il faut
absolument donner un armement encadré
bien sûr avec toute la réglementation
qui va avec aux policiers municipaux
c'est la condition pour avoir une équipe
un peu crédible donc on a qu'on est
passé pratiquement de 2,0 à voir agent
et on a une perspective de développement
encore donc maintenant on a une équipe
de un agent qui sont à la fois armé et
qui dispose de moyens de qualité et à la
prévention qui est très importante
il ya la présence eh bien peut-être le
rôle le plus important c'est de fédérer
les acteurs de la sécurité
d'attractivité public fédérer tout le
monde c'est à dire bien sûr au delà de
notre police municipale le lien avec la
nationale mais c'est aussi tous les
autres acteurs de la ville par exemple
où on vient de signer une convention
avec notre bailleur montrouge habitat
qui gère 2500 logements sur la ville
donc on travaille étroitement avec les
gardiens l'immeuble
mais aussi on a mis en place le fameux
conseil supérieur conseil de sécurité de
cesser d'espérer la le croit
la grand-messe qui permettrait tout ça
et on travaille avec des notifications
et ont travaillé avec tous les les
travailleurs de la jeunesse etc voilà
fédérer tout le monde met tout le monde
autour de la table et définir des
politiques et d'objectifs communs c'est
sarah des pouvoirs importants du maire
au delà des moyens qui sont fondamentaux
s'il en matière de country music hall
oui c'est bien vous avez raison de dire
il faudrait peut-être mieux parler de
politique de sécurité que de pouvoir de
police je vous proposais d' écouter la
directrice de la sécurité publique des
yvelines et isabelle thomas tisci
écouter nommé récemment qui parle
justement de ces rapports entre la
police et les maires la direction
départementale des yvelines qui assure
la couverture de la zone police
nationale sur le
sur ce département c'est à dire environ
un million deux cent mille habitants 1
est divisé en neuf circonscriptions de
sécurité publique entre mantes les murs
haut conflent sartrouville saint germain
en laye versailles elancourt plaisir et
rambouillet ces neuf circonscriptions
elle
elles ont autorité sur 80 une commune
donc ça fait beaucoup de maires en
contact avec la police nationale
ce partenariat il se fait au quotidien
il se fait
parce qu'il ya une alimentation
régulière soit du maire soin de soi du
commissaire de police sur une
problématique particulière
moi même j'ai demandé à chaque chef de
circonscription de faire chaque mois une
réunion de bilan mensuel lié l'analyse
des statistiques de la délinquance
il est une convention de coordination
chaque fois qu'il existe une police
municipale entre la mairie et la police
nationale si vous voulez il ya un
partage de compétences entre la police
nationale et la police municipale
mais du coup l'idée c'est que c'est un
peu le principe de subsidiarité c'est
que là où les mères peuvent investir le
champ et bien que les municipalités
investissent le champ pour que la police
nationale face à la délinquance et qui
est son domaine de compétence propre
puissent intervenir de manière efficace
sur ce champ là aussi
les maires ils peuvent investir un chant
qui notamment celui de la médiation et
ça c'est intéressant et de peut-être
davantage de proximité que la police
nationale et dans ce cadre-là la
connaissance du territoire la
connaissance d un des individus et
notamment des leaders
qui peuvent être des leaders positif au
débiteur négatif est assez intéressante
après il ya tous les dispositifs de
prévention auquel participent aussi la
police nationale alors dans les
dispositifs de prévention va également
beaucoup dans les établissements
scolaires
le renseignement territoriales
participent
vous êtes un major de sécurité le
le renseignement territoriale est en
contact également avec les élus le
donc il ya une relation de
également de proximité entre le
les
mr leur équipe municipale leur police
municipale et le renseignement
territoriales parce que les
interlocuteurs sont sont identifiés et
cette connaissance de
de l'environnement par le maire qui
connaît ses habitants qui peut qui à
leur tour d'un certain nombre de
deux problématiques de situations
particulières ça peut être une alerte et
les signalements qui sont faits sont
traités éventuellement par le
renseignement territoriale alors juste
évoqué voilà elle raconte les relations
entre autres la police nationale elle
mais d'une façon générale vous n'avez
pas de problèmes de dos relations avec
la police nationale
absolument pas bah ouais pardon je
prends juste à paroles et j'oserais
évoqué tout à l'heure madame tomatis et
que en règle générale nous faisons des
réunions plus que régulière avec la
police nationale
il me semble indispensable de le faire
et nous mettons autour de la table vient
surtout toutes les personnes concernées
par les problématiques que ce soit les
médiateurs que ce soit les présidents
d'associations dans les quartiers que ce
soit bien sûr notre police municipale ça
ne peut être que comme ça il doit y
avoir une très grande porosité entre
toutes ces acteurs pour justement faire
circuler les informations et démontrer à
la population que c'est un tissu complet
entre la rencontre les blés je dirais
les connaissances du terrain des
personnes qui sont sur le terrain des
associations également les médiations
aujourd'hui je dirais presque qu'on est
au cas par cas on ne peut plus même
s'ils ont une ville de 30 me comme
trente deux mille habitants de comme
plaisir on ne peut plus travailler sur
uniquement des quartiers on doit
travailler dans la dentelle et je sais
que mon collègue nicolas et dans ce
travail là aussi on travaille dans la
dentelle vraiment pour pouvoir avoir
cette proximité de prévention
d'anticipation et d'action derrière que
nous nous partageons en fonction des
compétences juridiques nationale et
police municipale nous aussi on est dans
un pré développement de police
municipale avec la ville des
clayes-sous-bois dès qu'ils nous
mutualisons parce que noir il n'y a pas
de frontières nicolas david justement
vous avez mis en place par exemple des
médiateurs dont certains quartiers alors
c'est pas tout à fait une police
municipale s'est pas tout à fait des
pouvoirs de police mais c'est ce sont
d'aider des personnes qui ont pour
vocation d'assurer le open lord en tout
cas la tranquillité publique
exactement alors on est une commune de
verrières
la particularité effectivement d'avoir
un quartier en priorité de la ville et
le bois de l'étang ce qui donne
effectivement un certain nombre de
possibilités à ses dires la ville de la
verrière avait passé cette possibilité
depuis près de quatre ans et donc c'est
vrai que dès qu'on est arrivé aux
responsabilités
on a mobilisé deux haltes eu une tour
olé qui sont financés à 95 % par l'état
par la préfecture et on a renforcé ses à
bobby lisez sur le terrain aux horaires
où ils sont les plus efficaces notamment
le soir le vendredi soir le samedi soir
pour faire une double approche je dirais
approche comme vous l'avez dit
tranquillité publique mais aussi une
approche prévention comme le disait je
le maire de plaisir à les jouer et je
l'espère j'ai donc approche prévention
et un travail peut-être plus un avec les
parents puisqu'on sait aujourd'hui que
les parents sont malheureusement souvent
dépassés ou et c'est une réalité parfois
complices et donc il faut vraiment les
remettre dans la boucle et et les nos
médiateurs qui connaissent le quartier
qui connaissent les familles elles ont
je dirais cette particularité la de
pouvoir parler aux parents ce que ne
peuvent pas vraiment faire des policiers
ils ont d'autres missions mais là on
peut vraiment remettre les parents dans
la boucle les alerter quand les jeunes
sont dehors à des horaires nous il ne
devrait pas l'être pour les alerter
aussi sur les agissements
les dégradations de biens publics ce
genre de choses pour vraiment que comme
le disent et marie jo ont des seins un
continuum que ce soit les parents la
police municipale les médiateurs la
police nationale voilà l'ensemble des
partenaires qu'ils soient soudés pour
assurer la tranquillité publique étienne
dangereux il ya beaucoup de mères qui
demande quand même d'un accroissement de
leurs pouvoirs en matière de sécurité
est ce que vous partagez cette
monter je crois qu'en effet c'est en
travaillant dans la dentelle comme il a
été dit travail en réseau on permet de
résoudre les problèmes
nous nous y ont des relations étroites
je vois tous les mois le commissaire de
police nationale et effectivement la clé
c'est c'est d'anticiper de prévenir dès
qu'il ya c'est la théorie du carreau
cassé et des quelque chose qui
équivalent à est une alerte qui est
faite par un des acteurs les parents ou
aux touts les associations notamment via
les réseaux sociaux qui sont plus en
plus utile et bien des fois que l'
alerte et fait chacun sont en guinée
doré c'est de trouver les réponses
donc c'est sûr qu'on pourrait mettre
davantage de moyens auraient tous
davantage de police municipale et on
connaît l'état de nos finances publiques
je parle pas de l'état l'huile de l'état
puisque les tarots galets réduit ses
moyens donc on est obligé de suppléer
par le comité municipal mais cercle la
question des moyens est importante parce
que si on n'a pas de moyens on n'est pas
crédible
il n'y a pas que les moyens notamment en
hommes
il ya aussi toute la capacité à
organiser ce réseau dans la dentelle
je crois que c'est fondamental voilà
donc c'est très applaudi les deux mais
il faut être
il faut être présent et ne rien et ne
rien laisser passer en réalité c'est ça
c'est ça la clé du succès ou être bon
roche c'est trop proche du territoire ce
qui se passe
il ya quand même aussi une nouvelle
criminalité qui arrivent là non je pense
à la cybercriminalité qui est plutôt
plus importantes notamment les
entreprises sont victimes de cette
cybercriminalité est ce que la haute si
vous êtes armé ou est ce que c'est ça ou
alors pour le coup quelque chose qui
sort des compétences des maires et que
la ville s'est passé ne nous ont pas
gens n'auraient alors pas coupé oui sur
les cybercriminalité notamment d'accord
le rôle des maires face à la
cybercriminalité
en ce sens oui c'est ça
alors sur la cybercriminalité c'est vrai
qu on a différentes approches on protège
déjà tous nos deux municipaux face aux
attaques puisque les mairies sont de
plus en plus l'objet d' attaque de cyber
attaques ont fait également en tout cas
nous sommes là derrière et je pense que
c'est le cas dans beaucoup d'autres
communes de la prévention auprès des
jeunes
on a eu tout un atelier récemment sur
les addictions et notamment les
addictions aux réseaux sociaux pour
apprendre aux jeunes à faire attention à
tous ces réseaux criminels qui se
développe en ligne voilà un petit peu
d'eau nos approches je dirais pour pour
lutter contre cette question de la cyber
criminalité
et puis une dernière les seniors parce
que les ignore malheureusement sont
souvent ou revoilà pour mme souvent dans
le piège de 2,2 de ce nouveau type de
criminalité reliée avec les réseaux ou
en lien avec internet et donc on défait
voilà de prévenir tout le monde alors on
a une cote total air las
les automatismes qui était la directrice
de la sécurité publique dans les
yvelines
il ya aussi la gendarmerie qui est
importante alors peut-être plus dans les
zones rurales et je vous propose
d'écouter le collège silimaire tortelier
kim commandant du groupement de
gendarmerie des yvelines
[Musique]
le groupement de gendarmerie des
yvelines que je commande depuis donc
l'été 2010 9
ces 700 militaires actives et 450
militaires dits de réserve sourd au
total donc près de 1150 personnels qui
sont répartis donc sur l'ensemble du
département des yvelines dans vingt
brigade territoriale et puis quatre
unités de sécurité routière
donc ça irrigué samaille en fait
l'ensemble du département et la
gendarmerie en tant que telle est
compétente sur 80% de ce territoire
mais en revanche ne couvre que 18 à 19%
de la population d ib le diacre donc
c'est le dispostif intégré d'appui
territoriales c'est une offre de service
qu'on a développés singulièrement
pendant le premier conflit n'en retenir
que c'est une équipe pluridisciplinaire
qui est à la disposition en fête des
mères comme des intercommunalités pour
répondre à un triptyque de risque ou de
menaces singulièrement qui sont
développées pendant le confinement le
premier risque si le risque cyber donc
on fait intervenir nos experts en
cybercriminalité qui prodigue des
messages de sensibilisation sur
l'hygiène informatique la robustesse des
réseaux etc
deuxième expert qu'on faisait intervenir
on peut toujours faire intervenir c'est
une offre des services qui est
permanente
ce sont nos formateurs relais en
désinfection et enfin au troisième
experts susceptibles d'intervenir ce
sont nos référents sûreté
ce sont des experts qui vont prodiguer
des conseils des avis afin de réhausser
le niveau de sécurité passive et à
civ des bâtiments et des personnels on
peut penser évidemment à des crèches et
des écoles maternelles des ateliers
bref autant de bâtiments communaux on va
lancer à titre expérimental cette
formation à la fin du mois de mars donc
précisément voilà à la disposition des
maires des élus des conseils municipaux
pour leur donner un des clés des outils
de manière à ce que face à des
situations tendues
c'est leur quotidien pran de voisinage
point de violences intrafamiliales
problème une intervention il puisse
faire en sorte de déminer passez moi
l'expression de désescalade est de faire
tomber la pression l'attention pour
essayer de trouver une solution
équilibrée et raisonnée entre les
différentes parties c'est pas forcément
intuitif
c'est ce que nous on dispense dans nos
écoles de formation donc on va essayer
effectivement de dupliquer au profit des
maires sur la base de mise en situation
pratique
en fait ce module de formation grâce à
un référent départemental de négociation
de crise qui a été formé au gign que à
versailles satory
j'en suis intimement persuadé je vous
dirais qu'on a causes liées à ce qui
nous fait ce cet ancrage commun c'est
justement c'est l'ancrage territorial
nous sommes présents je l'indiqué on
vraiment au coeur des territoires où
sont les élus autre point commun nous
incarnons de près ou de loin une forme
d'autorité publique les élus et les
gendarmes
autre point commun nous sommes forme de
service public et enfin jamais dire la
contrepartie de tout cela autorités et
ça à ce public c'est la redevabilité que
nous devons à la population nous ne nous
mettons notre existence notre légitimité
les uns comme les autres que grâce et
pour la population
alors c'est intéressant ce qu'elle est
il y est j'ai disposé n'arrive
malheureusement presque au terme de
cette émission je l'avais à votre
sentiment à chacun est ce qu'au fond la
sécurité 10 et les maires sont en
première ligne mais est ce que c'est la
sphère de tous justement la table de
cette coopération entre la police et les
maires l'existant ce travail de maillage
du territoire
la police municipale c'est une prise de
conscience générale
je crois qu'on a tout un travail à faire
auprès de la population également pour
recréer la confiance avec la police
municipale et même la police nationale
il ya pas mal d'activités qui se met en
place il y à des rencontres qui se font
avec les jeunes la police nationale
organise des rencontres dans des
gymnases pour démontrer ce qu'est la
police nationale pourquoi il agit de
telle façon
et donc cette cette connaissance est
très important parce que comme on disait
tout à l'heure je crois que quand on ne
connaît pas si comme pour la cyber
attaque
quand on ne sait pas se servir de
certains routiers aux campeurs ne
connaît pas eh bien on est beaucoup plus
inquiet et on est moins collaboratif
donc la collaboration vient aussi de la
connaissance et notre rôle en tant que
maire c'est cela c'est de faire
connaître et c'est de faire savoir mais
je voudrais dire deux mots rapidement
nos responsabilités tous les maires les
prenne vraiment on est en première ligne
aujourd'hui et ce qui est important
c'est de savoir comment la justice nous
accompagne également parce que le
problème de fond est là c'est à dire que
nous faisons que je crois tout
notre travail la police nationale
municipale les maires les associations
les médiateurs tout le monde mais
derrière il faut qu'on soit accompagnée
donc je sais un appel très fort à l'état
en disant attention
accompagnez nous parce que tout le monde
est rusé sur le territoire parce que les
choses ne vont pas aussi loin qu'elle
devrait aller derrière sur des prises de
décisions importantes au niveau de la
justice
j'ai terriblement sentiments oui plus
d'accord ils paient un tribut tic et à
très vite élus locaux police nationale
et j'utilise c'est vrai que souvent on
est un peu découragé mais ce qu'on
apprend que les délinquants on peut être
arrêté par la police nationale à notre
intermédiaire ou non à quelques jours
après ils sont de nouveau présents à
leur quartier donc c'est vrai que c'est
décourageant la justice est important
moi je pense que c'est effectivement l
affaire de tous mais il faut pas non
plus croire que les mères peuvent tout
faire
vous parlez la cybercriminalité je crois
clairement ça nous échappe
on n'a aucun moyen d'être efficace pour
lutter contre la cybercriminalité
c'est quand même si d'autres dimensions
la même manière le grand banditisme ou
la lutte contre le trafic de drogue
nous échappons aussi il faut être
terrible on n'est pas en mesure
d'intervenir et on sait que dans tout
mobile il ya des trafics souvent même de
dimension internationale donc tout ça
nous laisse à chacun son chacun son job
nous on doit être sûr la proximité le
réseau le lien ne rien ne rien laisser
passer et se servir de tous ces signaux
faibles que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
et si déjà on arrive au niveau au niveau
de la proximité à apporter des réponses
on aura fait un grand un grand travail
voilà l'on peut pas tout peut pas tout
il faut que tout le monde
les autres partenaires de l'état et
notamment la justice fassent aussi leur
travail
merci infiniment à son odorat l'occasion
et qui demande aux deux de leur parler
de ce thème qui est en train de changer
le sujet de l'épisode le sujet est
inépuisable merci beaucoup à tous les
trois les universités des mers
évidemment continue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]